-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a game
of "Box of Lies,"
but I'm gonna need some help.
So joining me now
is one of the stars
of the new James Bond movie
"No Time to Die,"
which opens in theaters today.
Please welcome Ana de Armas!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very happy.
Now, here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out an object,
and describe it
to your opponent.
Then they have to guess
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Deep voice ] Ana, why don't
you pick the first box?
-Of course.
-Number 5!
-Oh.
-8!
-5!
[ Audience shouting ]
-I can't hear anything.
-No, you can't hear.
Now they're yelling
every number.
Yeah, they're just...
[ Audience shouting ]
Yeah. They li-- 5's a --
Okay. Oh, this could be acting
right now.
I don't know if it's heavy.
-Doing this with heels
is not good.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Now, you open it,
and then you place it out here
so that the audience can see.
And the lying begins now --
or the truth telling begins now.
Here's where the game becomes...
-Okay.
-...exciting.
[ Light laughter ]
What?
This is very creepy.
Don't look.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not looking.
I can't see it.
-Who thinks of these things?
-Wha-- Who thinks --
are you asking --
Yeah. Okay.
-What to put in these boxes?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-All right.
Describe, describe.
-Wow.
-What?
What is in --
What is in box number 5?
-Oh, my gosh.
So...this is a --
-You're lying.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait.
-The -- So maybe
I don't know how to say
something in English, so...
-Okay.
-You know.
-Is it "pumpkin"?
-Okay, that sounds about right.
Topical.
-Okay.
With three people taking --
it's like a Jacuzzi pumpkin.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I just want to hear you say
"Jacuzzi pumpkin,"
like, forever, like...
"This is Jacuzzi pumpkin."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
[ Both laugh ]
-Okay.
-Gonna get better.
-Alright.
So, is there three people
in the pumpkin?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
What?
-Ah! In the Jacuzzi.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
-Okay.
One is...
[ Laughter ]
I really don't know
who these people are, but...
[ Laughter ]
-You should know them.
-They're -- They're...
[ Both chuckle ]
...murderers.
[ Laughter ]
They're, like, bad people.
-Oh, oh.
-This is bad people.
-Okay.
These are three murderers
in a pumpkin hot tub.
[ Laughter ]
Now, if this is a lie,
then I will give you
a million dollars.
There's no way you can be
making this up.
-Wait.
-I'm gonna say -- There's more?
-Smells good.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
I'm going to say...
Ana de Armas...
[ Laughter ]
...you are telling the truth.
[ Clears throat ]
-You sure?
[ Light laughter ]
-Yes.
-God damn it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did I -- Let me see it.
[ Bell dings ]
-Who are these guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yeah. You don't know them?
Oh, no, that's -- that's...
[ Both laugh ]
Yeah, that's from "Halloween."
That is Jar Jar Binks.
-This is "Friday the 13th,"
isn't it?
-That's "Friday the 13th."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I don't know what that is.
-Yeah.
I don't know why he's --
he's drinking in a Jacu--
[ Light laughter ]
-Looks like a shrimp to me.
-No, that's not a shrimp.
It's -- It's from
a "Star Wars" movie.
-Oh.
-A shrimp.
It's Jar Jar -- Oh, yeah.
-I don't know.
-Good. Alright. Here.
You can put that right here.
-Okay.
-Alright.
Which number shall I...?
-3!
[ Audience shouting ]
-I heard a 3.
I heard a confident 3.
And here we go.
[ Grunting ]
-You're so bad.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
It's so heavy. Oh, my gosh.
[ Both chuckle ]
♪ La, la-la, la-la ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Humming ]
-It's very tempting.
Like, I want to...
-Yeah, I --
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I get it.
It's a lot -- It's --
It's a box inside of a box.
And in there is a --
it's a bunch of butter knives
with a cable-knit sweater
over --
a tiny sweater over it.
I'm assuming this is
a Chris Evans reference.
[ Laughter ]
And it's --
a sweater over a bunch
of knives, butter knives.
♪♪
-What? No.
[ Laughter ]
-I wish I could --
-So, that's a Chris Evans
reference,
and you just went
and picked that one out?
That's very strange.
So, you knew
that that was there.
-Well, we knew that you were
gonna be on the show, so, yeah.
♪♪
You're in "Knives Out."
-No, I remember that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
So they probably thought
that that you would get it,
I'm assuming.
And then you would
have to laugh
and think of your memories
from being with Chris on set.
-I think you're also telling
the truth,
because you just said it,
like, very fast.
And, like...
-I wish it was funnier.
-Yeah, it's not that funny.
-No, it's pretty serious.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Think I'm telling the truth?
-Telling the truth.
-I'm lying.
-No, you're not!
-Yes. It's a "Marriage Story"
lunch box.
-Oh, my God.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Spinning Adam Dri--
[ Laughter ]
They're arguing.
-God damn it! Okay.
-Scarlett Johansson
and Adam Driver
are arguing with each other,
spinning around --
-I can see. Yeah.
-It's a music box.
Thank you. Hey.
That was some good acting,
I thought.
-That was so fast.
-That was quick thinking.
I thought -- Yeah, thank you.
I know.
Alright, here we go.
This one's for all the marbles.
Ana, this one's
for 10,000 points.
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Shouting continues ]
Oh.
Controversial choice.
I would have went with 7,
myself.
-This one's very light.
Very light.
-Oh, okay, very light.
Why would you do that?
Oh, maybe --
-Just to show you.
-Yeah.
But maybe you're -- No?
-I don't know.
-Okay, I don't know either.
It's very tricky.
-Why is this...
[ Laughter ]
What is this?
-If it's another pumpkin
with murderers in it...
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's -- it's --
♪♪
-I don't --
You're making a fa--
I have no idea what it is.
You're --
-Well, trust me,
this is very strange.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Ana, just take a breath...
-Okay.
-...and describe what you see.
♪♪
-Okay. So...
-[ Chuckles ]
-It's a turtle.
"Turtle"?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Turtle.
-Did I -- Turtle.
-Tur-- Tur-- Turtle.
-Tur-- Turtle.
-Turtle --
Oh, it's a turtle, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but instead of a...
-Shell?
-...shell...
-Uh-huh.
-...it's a hamburger.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like, they dressed the --
The -- The turtle lives
in the burger.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-"The turtle lives
in the burger" is so great.
-It would be a turtle burger.
-It's a turtle burger.
The turtle lives in the burger.
It's almost like
an acting exercise.
-It's on top of --
-"The turtle lives in
the burger. The turtle --
Okay, and let's yell, 'Action.'"
-Yeah.
-So, it's a turtle
inside of a burger.
-The shell is the burger.
-The shell is a burger.
-Yeah.
-That sounds like something
our props department would do.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But I'm not smelling
any hamburger.
[ Light laughter ]
And I got to use all
my senses here, with this game.
-You didn't smell the Jacuzzi,
either.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
That's true that I did not...
♪♪
-Ah. Ah.
-[ Laughs ]
-That might have been
a little give there.
You were like...
[ Light laughter ]
Why would you do that
if you were telling the truth?
Which means...
[ Both laugh ]
...Ana de Armas...
you lie!
[ Laughter ]
Let me see.
-Oh, come on! This is --
-Oh, my gosh! I did it again?!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
Finally, I did really good.
Wow!
-What is that?
-That was a good --
Turtle burger was good!
I like turtle burger.
We're going to put that
in the next game,
by the way, in honor of you!
-Thanks.
-Ana de Armas, everybody!